mon travail normalement ce n'est pas de
parler mais de photographier je
m'exprime à travers mes images
et bien ce soir pour une fois je vais
parler de ces images est en fait je veux
surtout parler de ce qu'ils ont initié
ce bâtiment se trouve place des fêtes
dans le 19e arrondissement il s'agit
d'un ancien lycée hôtelier désaffectée
maintenant depuis plusieurs années il se
trouve à un pâté d'immeubles de chez moi
ce dont je vous parlais sont donc à
quelque chose près mes voisins être
séparées par un pâté d'immeubles ce
n'est rien pourtant ça suffit pour ne
pas se voir depuis plusieurs mois ce
vieux lycée était occupée par des
centaines de migrants et je n'en savais
rien pour la petite histoire c'est grâce
à un post sur facebook que j'ai appris
que ces gens étaient là dans le besoin
il est à deux pas de chez moi et j'ai
découvert sur facebook
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
pourtant je peux pas dire que ce n'était
pas sensibilisé aux difficultés
rencontrées par les migrants j'avais
fait des reportages déjà mes premiers
datent de fin 2002 au moment où le
centre de la croix-rouge de sangatte a
été évacué et puis j'avais bien sûr
connaissance de l'afflux de migrants
dans la nouvelle jungle de calais j'ai
donc appris que ces gens avaient besoin
de vêtements alors j'y suis allé dans un
premier temps pour leur en apporter à ce
moment là c'est à dire en août l'année
dernière je faisais des photos
essentiellement dans le domaine de la
musique j'avais pendant longtemps été
journaliste reporter d'image pour la
télévision mais j'avais botté en touche
car cette manière d'exercer mon métier
ne me convenait pas et du coup j'avais
ainsi renoncer à ce qui m'anime est
pourtant le plus c'est-à-dire témoigner
et puis quand j'ai mis les pieds dans ce
couloir pour la première fois eh bien je
me suis souvenu pourquoi 1 jour de mes
21 ans j'avais choisi de devenir
journaliste rencontré donner la parole
mettre en lumière l'inhumain
bousculé ce garçon à côté de moi sur la
photo s'appelle abdou il est l'un des
premiers que j'ai rencontré il est venu
vers moi avec un grand sourire quand il
m'a vu traverser la cour du lycée pour
la première fois abdou et soudanais et
il avait atterri là après des mois de
galère sans trop savoir quel serait son
avenir et il était loin d'être le seul
dans cette situation
avec lui il était environ 700 l'été
dernier à survivre ici au lycée jean
carré ils venaient du soudan
d'afghanistan d'erythrée et il avait été
propulsé la par la guerre la famine la
dictature le manque de liberté il révèle
cette liberté comme lui abdel hamid
mahmoud au soudan il était banquier il
était aussi activistes c'est pour sauver
sa peau qu'il a fui son pays persécuté
pour ses idées progressistes
je les rencontrais un jour de tension au
lycée les esprits s'étaient échauffés
des bagarres avaient éclaté alors abdel
hamid mahmoud est allé chercher une
table qui l'avait planté au milieu de la
cour et ils s'étaient dressés pour
appeler au calme
plus tard il m'a demandé pourquoi tu
prends des photos je lui ai dit que si
je témoigne pas de ce moment et bien
demain ce bâtiment serait réhabilité ses
occupants seraient partis et pour
beaucoup il n'aurait jamais existé
à part pour les quelques riverains qui
s'en souviendraient peut-être je lui ai
dit qu'on ne pouvait pas accepter que
des gens vivent dans de telles
conditions que maintenant que j'avais vu
il était de mon devoir de témoigner
prendre des photos c'était ma compétence
à moi je n'étais ni médecin ni prof
j'étais photographe
j'ai passé un mois avec une amie
journaliste à y aller régulièrement à
recueillir des témoignages
j'ai vu des gens qui serrait les dents
courageusement devant un quotidien
difficile et un avenir incertain
j'ai vu des gosses aussi livrent leur
vie gosses jouent au ballon
j'ai vu des regards remplis d'espoir
d'autres et un d'autres encore en colère
j'ai répondu à comment cette vivre en
france j'ai écouté commencé de livres au
darfour ou encore à kaboul j'ai
visualisé des parcours des naufrages
comme celui d'abdul dont le bateau avait
chaviré
et puis j'ai photographié parfois pas
toujours d'ailleurs
j'ai expliqué que photographier ce n'est
pas un manque de respect non au
contraire photographier c'est une
reconnaissance de l'inhumanité dans
laquelle il se trouve
il faut pouvoir montrer pour bousculer
voir l'invisible
c'est prendre la responsabilité de
devoir y penser de pouvoir en débattre
de chercher à aider ou au contraire
d'assumer de ne pas le faire mais c'est
déjà une possibilité de briser le
silence après un mois rendre visite
régulièrement aux occupants du lycée
jean carré un petit matin d'octobre il a
été évacué
calmement ils sont montés dans des bus
vers un avenir différent
le bâtiment a aujourd'hui été
réhabilités et ils accueillent des
réfugiés dans de bonnes conditions
et puis j'ai été contacté pour
poursuivre ce travail à calais ici sur
ce territoire que vous connaissez sous
le nom de jungle ils ne sont pas 700 mhz
et 6000 une ville dans la ville
ou plutôt un bidonville qui a poussé
dans la zone industrielle
coincé entre la rocade et des sites
classés seveso la jungle ce sont des
quartiers des allées des lieux de vie de
culte des écoles c'est aussi une
cohabitation forcée entre les calaisiens
et ces personnes en transit qui rêvent
de l'angleterre
des mois des années de cohabitation et
d'interrogation de solidarité aussi
et puis le ras-le-bol c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant
de jour comme de nuit ils marchent le
long des routes capuche sombre sur la
tête baluchon à la main d'ailleurs
certains calaisiens par le 2 comme de
fantômes dont ils ont peur pourtant je
vous jure que ce gosse n'a rien d'un
fantôme
il s'appelle everest on s'est croisé au
détour d'une allée boueuse un jour de
décembre en voyant prendre des photos il
s'est approché il m'a demandé est ce que
tu peux me prédire mon avenir
everest vienne kirkouk en irak
il est chrétien et lui et ses parents
ont tous quitté sous la menace de dice
comme n'importe quel gosse il a des
rêves et il m'a dit dans un anglais
impeccable
un jour je serai professeur en
angleterre quand tu arrives dans la
jungle
il est fréquent qu'on t'invite à boire
le thé à discuter à partager un moment
de musique est là tu te rends compte que
rien ne différencie de tes autres tu te
rends compte que tu as parfois le même
âge que tu as parfois fait les mêmes
études
tu parles photo avec quelqu'un dont
c'est aussi le métier rien ne nous
différencie des habitants de la jungle
excepté bien sûr un contexte excepté
aussi une culture une religion une
langue c'est différent ce qu'on peut
aussi appeler richesse de se rendre
compte de cela et bien l'appréhension
laisse place à la curiosité parler avec
des gens qui ont traversé des maires et
des frontières pour fuir des conditions
de vie indignes
c'est mettre une réalité sur des images
télévisées comme cette famille qui vient
de mossoul en irak
les parents et leurs triplés ont
finalement réussi à rejoindre
l'angleterre
après avoir vécu tout l'hiver dans la
jungle parler avec eux c'est aussi se
poser des questions
pourrions-nous vivre de la sorte
aurions-nous la force de rester chez
nous ou alors prendrions nous la route
de l'exil pour sauver nos enfants nos
vies à chacun sa réponse la mienne je ne
la connais pas parce que je pense qu'il
est impossible de la connaître
tant qu'on n'est pas confronté à la
question brutale qui nous met au pied du
mur est-ce possible d'y répondre tant
que le mur ne s'effondre pas sur nos
têtes
pas sûr mais que cela nous empêche pas
d'y réfléchir
youssef le gamin sur la pancarte avait
16 ans il est mort fauché par une
camionnette alors qu'ils tentaient de
rejoindre l'angleterre
un accident tragique mais qui n'a rien
d'exceptionnel malheureusement pourtant
ce jour là ils ont été nombreux migrants
comme militant à vouloir marcher en sa
mémoire
noir sur blanc brandis à bout de bras
ils ont crié en silence nous sommes des
humains pas des chiens non au racisme
oui à la justice non au terrorisme
debout campé dans leur dignité ils ont
fait face aux forces de l'ordre
un face à face pour une reconnaissance
voir l'invisible la photographie m'aide
à cela d'ailleurs en argentique
si vous avez déjà tiré une photo vous
savez que le papier restent immaculés
tant qu'il n'est pas passé dans un bain
de révélateur
le révélateur permet de voir l'invisible
et bien pour moi manière plus globale
l'outil photographie qui lui même ce
révélateur sans lequel mon deuil ne peut
pas voir certaines situations mon
appareil photo
med a brisé cette pudeur qui parfois
m'empêche d'être curieuse des autres
à chacun son vecteur photographier le
mien c'est ce petit bout d'expériences
et de réflexions qu'il souhaitait vous
apporter ce soir trouvé son vecteur être
curieux voire merci